Dave's in Ohio hi Dave how are you
pretty good there how about yourself
better than I deserve what's up
all right first-time caller longtime
listener changes with money I'm not
really the most educated as a recently
have become really motivated to start
taking control of my situation and I
just had a question about a car loan
that I'm in kind of dependent I know it
can probably be postponed given the
current state of affairs of the world
but I was I had a question about
refinancing what do you owe on the car
car currently finances eighteen to fifty
eighteen thousand to fifty dollars
what's your interest rate my interest
rate is terrible at eight point eight
percent okay and have you investigated
what kind of a rate you can get I called
my uh I called my local credit union I
haven't done much more shopping around
but with my current credit score are
ranging between six seventy six eighty
working on fixing
I can get five point seven five percent
and a full twelve months
ah sure their term one attorney term
limit okay so what's your household
income between my wife and I pink home
would be about seventy five thousand
okay what's your other car worth I have
my wife's car yep perfect that I see
she's about the same nineteen thousand
okay she owes that much on it yes that's
how much he owes holy crap she have
$40,000 in car debt and you only make
seventy a year and you know what the I
took your class a couple years ago
through my employer apparently a fine I
had another car absolutely and I had a
car that I was holding on to and
trying to come up with justifications to
to hold on to it and I've just recently
sold it so to me that stepped in the
right direction you sold it and got a
eighteen thousand dollar debt no no no
no no no the car was paid off before I
sold it but the fund the money to a
savings account okay you guys have too
much invested in vehicles that are going
down in value based on your income and
based on the total debt that you have
and so you probably need to select one
of these vehicles my guess is it'll be
yours and sell it and move down into a
hoopty and then let's work a plan with
you and your wife together which is what
we taught you when you're taking the
class you don't have a hurt car your car
debt we have $40,000 in car debt and
that's way too much when we make $70,000
household income and so we are going to
have to reduce our car debt and then
we're going to get out of debt
completely baby step one as you save a
thousand dollars to is you list all of
your debts smallest to largest and you
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and you attack the little
one when you're doing that you look at
your cars and say if our cars totaled
more than half our annual income we have
too much invested in vehicles and if we
can't get out of debt inside of two
years everything but our house we have
in a vehicle is keeping that from
happening we have too much invested in
vehicles both of those tell me you have
too much invested in vehicles and so I
would not refinance your $18,000 car I
would sell it not what you were looking
for but actually dude if you do this
stuff you're gonna look back a few years
from now and go I don't know any card
debt because that Dave Ramsey guy was a
jerk when I called him on there
cuz I Love You Man I'll smack you too